hey guys and welcome to another episode
of my one-hour flippin challenge so it
finally got the money back from my 30
accounts and I decided I wanted to
actually just do some shred up flipping
with the extra money I still like
another 30 mil on items I have yet to
sell but hundred 15 mils are going to be
going with today so that should be
enough we're gonna do some more
expensive high-volume
items as well as doing some items like
armor oh god swords maybe I'm in love
tortures we're gonna go have a look
pretty much everything and I see what
that's the best margin for this I am
gonna be using ji tracker they are a
sponsor of mine so go check on my going
to be using it mostly for item ideas
sometimes it's kind of hard to think of
items just straight out of nowhere so
it's hanging you still have something
like this and yeah let's get started one
hour let's go so the first thing that
we're showing here was the dragon dart
tip and now first I'll check if the
volume is very high not very much
selling this one it's good that for now
room darts decent and we'll try battle
stabs maybe room darts have a very nice
margin in them right now we're gonna do
9k room darts the 1.10 20 to 1 0-60
pretty much that's the 40 GP just on
that item and next up we'll do err
battle staff they trade really quickly
now 30 GP is not a lot however I'm
hoping I can flip this quickly so it
doesn't take up too much money cuz if we
do like 5 kt that's gonna be like well
put in there for now and to see if they
buy quickly and now because that's like
a third of our money so that's probably
not worth it that's gonna take a while
ok err orbs are actually really good
that's 38 GP on air orbs Dylan 1 the air
orbs is 10,000 so was a student and 993
is pretty good okay all the air bottle
stabs already came through nice and
quick for that item and we could still
saw them off in the medium price of
about ninety seventy we're selling them
all for forty five three five four we
bought them for forty five 205 that's
actually a 150 K in like just a few
minutes that's actually pretty good
we'll probably go ahead and do the other
5k of those once we get the money back
dragon bones have a pretty good margin
on them about 20 GP and that they're
reasonably cheap for this kinda item
I'll do 7000 those guys and they should
buy extremely quickly look at that money
back okay so a reasonably cheap item
here is the obsidian plate legs only but
a mil however is about a 20k margin on
them and it very high limit is what I
really like about this item so now nine
three into
9:8 one is like 12k it's not amazing but
it's a pretty cheap item so go ahead and
do maybe ten of those in width
next up I might do arches rings they
fluctuate so quickly but I will give
them a try so two seven six one and two
two seven nine four is actually pretty
damn good so we can do seven of these
guys and hopefully we can that be a nice
150 to 200 K I think in profit and
another really commonly used item is the
amulet fury
why that doesn't pop up when you type it
that way I don't know but maybe if it
has a 20k margin we can flip to use
pretty quick as well put a 16 K margin
so I'm not terrible and we'll go do
seven of these guys as well okay we have
our first purchase ring coming through
427 6-1 and we are gonna try to sell it
for 27 nine or something like that so
it's a 30k profit per Archer ring which
is nice okay we sold a lot pretty much
right away and we already bought two
more which is good to see arches rings
are always a really nice and quick and
it's about 30k a pop and seven of those
we're looking to make 200k Plus on this
one item okay a big offer came in for
the air or bad 993 that's pretty nice
and how much are we selling this for
again air or I think it's like a 30 GP
margin which is very excellent that's
gonna be close to 300 K in profit when I
sell these off for 1 0 to 8 and we
finally have some Furies coming through
for 29 to 3 and we were gonna sell them
for but a 13k profit so pretty decent
and next up we're gonna continue doing
some of these highly popular rings next
up gonna try the Berserker ring probably
only like a 15k margin on that one as
well but 27 70s but we saw the floor and
we're gonna try that's still higher and
Alex actually much higher than I
normally expect from this item about 35
K on this one as well so I do want to do
the other 5k battle slabs for that but I
want to do this margin while is still
around and we're gonna do seven of these
guys because we'll need 45 mil to do
another 5k pal slabs which is pretty
pricey to be honest we'll take this
opportunity also to drop in the amulets
up fury 429 3 9 and I'll probably pull
out the dragon bones now cuz it almost
all come through and we're selling them
for 2250
which is still a 18 GPA margin which is
decent so we bought them for 39 70 and
were hoping to sell them for 14 over 70
so just about 100k from the dragon bones
okay the rich and Champa has a 25 just
be marching on it and I think they are
7k perching Champa or for the buy limit
sorry and yeah 7 Kate so we'll do just
shy of 7,000 6500 that's about 8 mil
invested there that's pretty decent and
we sold the plate legs off pretty much
right away interesting below pipes say
they have a 32k margin on them so we'll
do that just because they're nice and
cheap and I'll just go and check the
margin manually we bought it for 27 70
and consult for 27 3 6 about 35 k in the
blowpipes and we'll put it in for 7 as
well so about 20 mil invested their
Furies have sold off nice and quick room
tarts are pretty slow Wow all these
dragon bones came through in one instant
22:49 that's nice
blowpipe circumvents are so quick it
already at two now look to you something
like tassets and the margin might be
better than that but still pretty pricey
we only do like two of those at a time
girls leather coif could do that or
leather top sorry and okay we have two
already sold for 27 70 and another - are
we lined up or one sorry let's put two
mil afore this guy $19.99 and we can
sell it for
19 for nine that's actually 50k and
we'll do seven of Kirill's leather top
manis tsardom sword has gone very cheap
only 600 cave item got another to toxic
blow pipes coming through and we're
gonna sell them for twenty seven seventy
hopefully okay we sold offer ready for
1998 that's 50k I already broke even on
that and we have another one coming
through actually now I may pull the
Berserker rings out I feel like they
have changed prices we haven't gotten
one in quite a while and I don't know
her over a salad fork either okay we
just insta sold it what do we sell it
for
2765 oh wait that's fine with me okay
even though the band of Scott's wears
gotten quite a bit more expensive we'll
do it just because we have the cash
right now
five five nine one well we'll see if the
margin as I guess first okay it's like
another 35 K not terrible
and we'll do the full eight or seven -
the one we already checked leaves us
with twenty seven mil name is old the
leather coif ready or at the leather top
I should say I think when the Polti room
darts out we've gotten 42 under of them
so far but it's about half well not
quite halfway but it's a pretty slow
item the occult necklace is really cheap
and has pretty much a 20k margin on it
and G trackers saying it trades a lot so
when it seems like a good item to do
pretty sure if lemon is eight seems to
forget to me I've never actually tried
this item before eight look at the
buying quantity that's extremely high
alright we'll give that a try okay we
sold off another two krills leather tops
for another 100k proffer right there
nice to see alright there we give all
the Arabs have come through for one zero
of two eight were profiting yeah and
that was like a hundred K or something
next up we're gonna check the occult
necklaces in we got him for six twenty
or in sounds like six forty okay we sold
one benzos got so he bought another one
sold off all the quills leather Kois
that was a really nice item and we've
sold off two of the occult necklaces so
far leaving us with 71 mil okay we're
gonna try the dragon fire shield it only
says 20k or something like that but 10
190 and we're buying it for ten to four
six that's actually 50k which is
reasonable so we'll do seven I suppose
we have the money not quite we'll do six
so each shield is roughly a 50k profit
so that's gonna be three newark a from
the six dragon fire shields which is
good all right the next item I'm kind of
looking at here is e2 rocks
armor set we're buying four three two
nine nine and we'll sell it for three
two five eight that's about 40km that
one the occult necklaces are all sold
off for six three eight okay we reduced
the ban of Scots for 255 eight five and
it sold off right away
we're still getting about 25 canvas so
it's a decent flip for mando Scott
swords okay we finally sold off all of
the room darts and not a great profit
there but it was something okay black
dragon leather actually is a 100 GP
margin nearly on it so yeah let's go try
this ji tracker is showing actually
quite
it traded for hours well we don't have
enough for that I was checking 4k for
now and boom maybe pull this out my god
a green dragon leather actually has a 50
GP margin on it as well as we'll go
ahead and do and pretty much the max of
that for 9,500 okay we did drop the
toxic below pipes down just to sell them
off gunned down to 27 40 so we lost a
little money on the last bit but it's
not terrible loss overall we have like
4,000 dragon leather coming through
right now 435 17 now we did have to
adjust the price so we're gonna recheck
it again quick face pose but we did drop
down to like 40 GPA is a margin but
still that's really good and 3 yeah this
thing fluctuates so much 36 to 3 was
what was that I'm gonna try 36 and so
these black dragon ads are selling
reasonably quick too now the Greens
recognize we'll have to go check again
so just to put it into perspective if I
sell all 9500 of these I'll make around
500k profit from this one if I sell all
of these guys currently going to be
getting about a mil in profit which is
just absolutely foggers I almost do
eternal dudes around here and there are
22 K margin and not too expensive of an
item 44 8 6 into 44 3 9 that's a 40k
margin and we're gonna do seven and
that's all I can actually afford anyway
it's a perfect okay we sold off about 3k
green dragon leather so far so that's
about 150 K in profit just from that so
far and we've sold off a ton of deep
black dragon leather but we are getting
pretty low in time here so I'm probably
gonna pull out I mean oh now all the
offers are pretty good well this one I
want to sell off quickly
so we're gonna drop this down to maybe
fifty five six five I just don't wanna
be stuck with anything okay we finally
sold off the last deep black dragon
leather for 36 10 we're looking at
probably four or five there K and profit
just from these four thousand so far we
have another 3086 to sell so we really
want to sell these oftentimes sighs just
a insane margin for something has
mundanes black dragon leather now we
only have 13 minutes left how
for battle saps buy and trade
ridiculously quickly normally so even if
there's a margin like this what's this
well oh good we'll do that never mind
and go forward mall and it's a 10k limit
however they're just so expensive
52 yeah we'll do 6k a vote so I meant to
drop this down to 55 65 but I [__]
forgot to put a K on it so what do we
sell it for 5502 god dammit and we have
the last three two rocks armor sets
coming through I was not paying
attention but they all came through
we're selling them off for thirty two
nine nine right yeah I must spin it okay
whistled off the eternal boots already
for forty four eight five nice to see
and the battle slabs I guess we'll start
to sell they're coming through so quick
but it's only 10 minutes left animals
all right guys nine minutes left well
hopefully this will all sell off and
we'll be back when the timer's done
alright guys we only have 30 seconds
left we're gonna pull out all the offers
and see where we're at now keep in mind
we started at 115 115 Milla should say
um see how we have about 2k or 1200 of
the black dragon ID and about a K of the
battle stabs but let's see where we
ended I'm pretty confident about this
one I think we may have made a couple
mil it's very least so 117 Mills is very
promising and let's see how much we made
from one hour of kind of flipping just
anything really we made two point three
mil not my absolute best but one of my
best for sure I really enjoy just
flipping high-volume items like whips
Berserker rings Archer rings and doing
battle stuff and stuff like that just
get you a really solid for our profit
now I didn't either by a hundred mil for
this so it's not extremely cheap but
yeah anyone can really do it alright
guys hope you enjoy the video if you did
don't forget to leave a little like and
I will see in the next one